hey subs and welcome to the series where
we explore all the hidden things in dark
souls 2. as usual let's not use the like
and the dislike system as a measure of
appreciation instead let's use it as a
point system if you know everything in
this video then leave a dislike if you
learn something new though feel free to
leave a like decide now whether you want
to play this game and let's get into it
number one as displayed on screen by my
brilliant accuracy with the moonlight
greatsword if you damage one of these
kobolds then they'll all come and attack
you i don't know if you've ever tried to
hit one of them with your fists when you
first start the game but it's really
damn hard it's possible though see your
reward for this amazing feat is getting
ripped to shreds you earned it if you
found the last boss too easy on your
first playthrough don't worry number two
is here for you because i almost feel
like from decided to make the start of
new game plus in the tutorial harder
than the end of your first playthrough
in new game as soon as you start you're
surrounded by hollow falconers who are
exclusive to new game plus as far as i
know these falconers are a hundred
percent true to their name they throw
falcons at you which will try to peck
your eyes out which really is just that
first experience that every masochistic
souls player wants
number three after a welcoming start in
new game plus you go into this shack
where old women make fun of you for
being destined to die over and over
again it's great ever wonder though what
happens if you give them the sword to
the face that they so truly deserve the
one named strowan gives six human
effigies and her sisters give none so
it's not entirely worth it but sometimes
you can't put a price on satisfaction
speaking of which you'll notice that the
old women have names that's number four
it's never mentioned in game so i don't
really expect you to leave a like for
not knowing this one but in the official
guide it tells you their names based on
when each of them talks in the cutscene
the outspoken one in the middle is
called strowan and the other two are
called griant and morel
number five relates to their housemaid
milibeth milibeth the housemaid handles
the chores for the fire keepers and as
such she's holding a ladle and yes i
know what you're thinking we want that
ladle we need it it's all we ever wanted
in a weapon so right now she's not that
happy with us because we killed the fire
keepers her family has been watching
over for generations and if we kill her
she won't even give us her ladle so
here's how to get it if you kill the
ogres on the beach near the stone coffin
then she'll give it to you just so it
can help you on your journey you have
proven yourself to the forest
we have little to offer
except perhaps these
may they bring fortune to your journey
how a ladle will help you on your
journey is beyond me it breaks in like
10 hits and call me crazy guys but i
think this might be a joke weapon
goodbye ladle oh i mentioned the stone
coffin just before and this is number
six so if you're like me you got into
the coffin and you couldn't quite
realize what changed and it's quite
ingenious really something about your
character does change when you get in
but you're instantly attacked by enemies
when you get out so it's unlikely that
you'll notice
the coffin swaps your things betwixt
changing you from a man into a woman or
vice versa seven there's a hidden path
off to the left here with an ogre
further along if you manage to kill him
this early in the game then you'll get a
stone ring which increases the amount of
poise damage you do to enemies it's a
great early game ring number eight have
you ever wondered what you'd get if you
managed to light all the torches and
things betwixt it just feels like you
should get something but maybe i've been
playing too much legend of zelda because
nothing happens if you do
now 9 is a door and a pathway that's
fairly hidden if you made this jump
within the first tree on the right then
you might have noticed this ladder on
your way back climb it jump down to a
slightly higher platform and there's a
door with a cracked red eye orb inside
off to the right
and number 10
like in every souls game there's this
nest where you can drop items and
receive other items in return
in dark souls 2 there are four different
items you can put in the nest for
different tiers of rewards prism stones
give crappy rewards like homewood bones
or burrs small smooth and silky stones
give titanite souls effigies and cracked
orbs smooth and silky stones give
different types of upgrade stones and
petrified something gives slabs a great
ring or a range of weapons one of the
rarest weapons you can get is the
channelers trident and you oh look i got
a trident awesome yeah if you drop
smooth and silky stones here you have a
chance of getting the trident which is
technically only a reward for trading a
petrified something but sometimes you
can trade as smooth and
they dropped another trident
oh my god
go on a journey without rest
you